yeah yeah you're gonna feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than itself.
There's been a change in the image of thought, that's what it is, that's what it is, that's what
it is, the internal structure, as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from
the subject, like she'll send me a text asking a question and then i'll send a text back.
you know because i always text back within relatively short period of time for anybody
for anything quick on the ball, yeah, and then and then i and so my response to her will like
respond and then ask a question and then like two to three weeks later i'll get her, i'm not even
kidding i'm not even joking that's just i'm like really two to three weeks is how long it took for
the yes, you know you know who's the worst you know who's the worst texter is a i don't know if
you've ever had a texting exchange with him. i've never had anything that i would call an exchange
with him, right? because he doesn't respond. he just doesn't respond. i sent him happy birthday like a
couple weeks ago no response, like that's an implicit i know i went out of my way to text him happy not
like it wasn't a facebook, you know, it was it was a personal text and nothing nothing from that kid.
he's terrible. i think uh yeah but i i i think i find that to be just like to me it's just fucking rude
right, like it's just what it is: complete obliviousness to the rhetorical situation.
some people just get like i know that he's he does that though so then i just kind of like well
that's just who he is. it is it is that it's just who he is is a rude dick.
but he's not, he's not rude face to face. he wouldn't just like if you said something to him
right in front of him he wouldn't just turn away, right? so so here's the thing nate you're seeing
that as a positive quality? yeah, that he wouldn't turn away from you face to face, it's like well
okay see he's not that bad of a guy i'm like i guess that okay i get that he's not involved in
genocide, that doesn't however make him a good guy, right? no no it doesn't bad texture baseline criteria.
i mean in the texting thing for i mean and i recognize like i just have my phone with me
all the time, right? like so if i get a text i know right away and i also know if i don't respond
to a text within like the sort of consciousness moment like it'll it'll go off my screen and i
won't see it again, so i just always respond as soon as i see anything and i get that not everybody's
like that but i don't understand how it takes two days to respond to a text like you did not look
at your phone nathaniel you're like this all the time like you'll go a fucking week and just not
respond respond to the text not a week i'll go like two to three days like especially if we're
traveling or somewhere like you know i was but let me ask you do you just not look at your phone
during that time at all yeah pretty much you just never look at so you have a watch? no i mean i have
a regular watch i have a regular watch okay that's what i'm saying so because like for instance i use
this to find out what time it is yeah so right so we have a watch you know there's a clock on the
i also don't know what time oh you have clocks? that's those are always useful.
well and that and the the kind of like relentless reflexivity that derrida
employs and that you know that you have to kind of employ through the book i mean that's what makes
it kind of not self-helpy to me or at least it's like a a version of self-help that's almost
incoherent like where uh because what derrida does like when he intervenes into levinas for instance
levinas kind of offers a policy right i mean in terms of embracing the other whereas derrida
introduces all these complications not necessarily via hegel but when he's talking about the violence
that's constitutive of in relationality that makes it much more confusing to make a choice
even though he says you do have to make a choice in a decision right it it makes it more difficult to
like to decide on your orientation or your style of engagement that was the problem when i wrote that
like the notion of the self and help what about the dash hold on yeah but that that was a big moment
for me when i was like hey when i read these sorts of moves there are two kinds of things that i hear
one is a sincere effort to inhabit the discourse and the other is like a total dismissiveness of
of otherness right and then that that next sentence is for me i was like wait why do i think they're
different things like why do i think they have a different moral inflection what happens if
like one person's like i'm not saying i'm not saying that the person doesn't believe and feel that
they are sincerely trying to inhabit it but that doesn't make it any less appropriative right and
So to me I was like, oh my gosh, that realization for me was a big realization of like these literally
are the same thing, like the sincere effort to attend ethically to this thing is an appropriative
violent way of rejecting the other. Like it literally is the same thing, not just like different sides of the
same coin. It's the same, you know, it's the same side, right? You know, yeah, like structurally ontologically
it's the same. It might be a a different, um, experientially or phenomenologically, right? It feels
different. It's like I feel like I'm trying to do this and I trust that you are, I trust that somebody
else is, but that's one of the important things for me about Derrida and Nietzsche is that they don't
they don't run away from the appropriative impulse of humanity, right? Whereas certain thinkers like I
mean bringing up Barad again but, right, they want to like completely wouldn't be a podcast without it
right? right? Diane's Diane's Levinasian inclination and and I like seriously, it's important that it's out
there. I really do, but that Levinasian inclination in Totality and Infinity especially, it really wants to
forestall violence. It really wants to say let's have a place of peace, and it's like that's the desire for
purity, yeah, right? That is the place of extreme violence, yeah, yeah, you know? And and I get I mean
I get it too, right? I get and that's the thing that I'm trying I'm trying to do justice to the desire
and that's how Levinas talks about the desire for transcendence. Like I'm trying to do justice to that
that desire and not simply say, you know, well you can't have the purity. The desire for purity is
fascistic. It's like I understand that the desire makes sense to me. The desire is is generous in
its implications, but you just or it's generous in its intention but not in its implications, you know?
right? right? yeah, and and also just the notion that relationality itself is not simply or only positive
right? I mean there's it's fraught and there's destructive potential in relations always, so something
something like fascism does not preclude relationality, like that its engine is relations. Fascism
doesn't actually desire unity, it needs the other to destroy it, right? So it's like it requires that
kind of relational engine. So the people that assume or at least posit that that relationality or
difference is sort of just imbued with this progressive ethical potential, it just seems like a little bit
I don't know, misguided or or just too optimistic. It's just like yeah, it's certainly hopeful, but I also
take the I also take the line and I think there's something to this which is like and this is a kind
of Foucault approach, it's like well let's give it a fucking try and see, right? Like we haven't done we
haven't thought uh on top we haven't thought relationality on an ontological like we just haven't
thought that way and I think that in principle you're right but in practice it's like right it's kind of it's
kind of like hey it may turn out that if the left actually gained ascendancy that it would be tyrannical
because I certainly see elements of the left that are tyrannical but let's fucking try it, like let's
see if it plays out because we we know what happens when the right has ascendancy and it we've seen
that so let's at least try this one for a little while. yeah, no, yeah, yeah, I get that. Yeah, I mean the
only thing the reason why like something like Nietzsche's overman for instance is more interesting than like a
Baradian ethics is because the overman do you mention the overman in these lectures maybe like
once? yeah, yeah, yeah, just it's an aside sort of. yeah, I mean something like the overman is the perfect
response to Hegel and I was just writing about this because it's basically incomprehensible and it's
deliberately incomprehensible because comprehension is still within the horizon of consciousness, so to
make it enigmatic like that and not like a self-help policy like be the overman, that's what makes it
such a forceful concept because it's like it's transgressive rather than explicitly progressive
and which makes it it's not necessarily like what happens if the overman were actualized? Nobody knows
and it's not necessarily a good thing. I mean it's like it's a breach. It's a violent imposition
of difference, right? There's a great concept. So this has been all over my sci-fi class and the the term in
the sort of sci-fi or futurist world not just science fiction but also sort of techie Elon Musky kind of
stuff is the singularity, right? And the and the singularity all I mean they're taking it from
physics and it's a term from physics that refers to the event horizon of a black hole, which is the
point at which the laws of physics don't apply, and that's all that's the only positive thing that you
can say about it is we don't fuck or we know that our current understanding doesn't work. That's all we
can say, um, and they're thinking they're using this as the moment in which ai becomes self-conscious and
makes you know in the next 40 years or whatever that's going to happen, that will like rules that
We establish to configure that go out the window and explain what happens. Yeah, exactly. The only
thing that we know is we have no fucking idea. There's no predictive model, there's no sense of
causality, none of the the only thing we know is that those won't work, right? Like, that those won't
give us and it's it's actually really neat to connect that to the way, like Deleuze uses the term singularity
which he's taking it from math, right, not from the physics version, but the way i'm like that's the
interesting way of thinking and Levinas uses it as well. Singularity like the this way of using the
singularity. Now what they mean in terms of singularity is an individual that's not individuated, that's not
part of a general uh general specific dialectic um, so the thisness, the hesiety, right, like right, um, but i feel
like those two concepts are deeply deeply related and it's like so to me i've just the singularity
has just been a term that i'm like there needs to be much more done with this term like there's a lot
about that intersection because you would have to think about the hesiety or the thisness
is has to be the moment at which none of the that's what it means can work anymore, doesn't work
right, and and in terms of alterity or otherness, right, like that would in other words you can't bring
your concepts to bear, right? There's not a sense of comprehension or intelligibility or whatever, like
that those things just don't don't work. Yeah, now the reasons they don't work is why where that falls
apart because the reasons they don't work is that simply because we haven't figured out, right, what's
going to happen meaning they will work at some point in the future they just haven't yet, but well what
if they just don't though has anyone in physics posited that, like maybe that just doesn't work
like ever? I mean i'm sure like i i mean yeah, to me the funny thing is when you think about the black
hole things it's clearly a point where all of the mathematicians have just gone like and so we've
called it, we've given it a name, the event horizon and the singularity and all that is, and same with
the same with the black hole in general, right? Like this is just like this is a term for we have no
fucking idea what's happening here, right? Like and and so we create a word to comprehend our
incomprehension, you know? So it's i mean that's what it's doing it's like it's a placeholder thing of
like and now we talk about it like there are such things as black holes and it's like that's ridiculous.
There's no such thing as a black hole, that's a concept for we don't know yeah and we can't know
you know and there's a i mean and we can use conceptual or concepts to kind of like get like
around it a little bit because i mean my understanding of one thing of a black hole is that it has to do
with like that the the other form of a singularity is like this a singular point of mass that is so dense
that's right the gravity that's right the gravitational pull is so strong that not even light can
escape it and it's like light can't escape that's a dynamic that we have no capacity i mean the reason
that there's this like the point at which you the laws of physics break down there's like we have
literally no capacity to see it because the light never comes back to us, right? Right. Well in that
point like so i i have a question: like do they in physics is it usually positioned like it's they
they have a failure to comprehend it and that eventually our knowledge making practices will
be sufficient that we can actually like sort of equate is that the assumption because that's
basically it's sort of yeah it's like i mean a Kantian sort of presupposition there and i mean
i'm wondering because what you just said Nathaniel kind of points like you could obviously shift that
the little Hegelian or Niels Bohr or Bohrsian shift where it's like actually it's not a fault
of you know our practices it's not a bug it's a feature there's an ontological inconsistency that's
part of both the knowledge making apparatuses and the that interference between us and the material
world so those are the kinds of the relationship between gravity and light correctly then suddenly
we'll be able to explain it well so but those are the kinds of things that shift that cause the sort
of Newtonian to quantum shift right that Einstein was on the cusp of and didn't really buy into or
whatever it's like you know that that those circumstances i mean having the technology to
for instance shoot an electron which wasn't available in the 20th century like that produces
a fundamental shift in you know now what we call some atomic some atomic physics versus you know
larger uh physics but yeah i mean i you know the i spent i mean one could speculate i don't know
enough and obviously the math is way fucking beyond me and always will be and i don't care to but um
but yeah like i mean i think that the idea the premise is at some point we will figure out a way but
that figuring out a way might mean reorienting reconceptualizing math I mean who knows yeah yeah
well I think one problem with with math and even like differential calculus is that the basic move
of math is quantification right and if you're dealing with things that are fundamentally constitutively
non-bounded and or unbounded then math has a problem but that's why the electron probably like is it a is
it a wave or is it a yeah uh is it a point right like I mean it's a part and that's just one that's
like you know for conventional thinking just doesn't make any sense right like and even conventional
thinking within physics it's like it doesn't make any sense like right how can it be both a wave and a
particle yeah yeah a wavicle right we can call yeah we can we can always Brangelina it somehow yeah
I think somebody actually like like offered that as a solution like it's both at the same time both and
you know wavicle but it's still I mean it just it undermines and but you know what science usually
does is they say hey there's this really exceptional case of undermining the logic of identity and we
treat it now as a really exceptional case despite the fact that it's constituent of literally every
single atom of every single element of everything but it's still only operative at that level because
at the level of molecules for instance we don't experience that nobody sees that nobody knows that
and it doesn't matter it's like I bet the more we learn about it it will
like we're going to talk about all those sort of you know at some point we're going to talk about
like all those sort of vague forces of coincidence and various other things and be like ah turns out that
is entirely all about like subatomic particle interactions which are constitute every single
particle
well what was the in all the spirit and all that shit all those sort of non-reductive things
I um Thomas Kuhn is always good I think for something like this and thinking about like say
Ptolemaic astronomy where oh yeah you know the movement of the stars and trying and saying like
look this is the general model it works but there are exceptions there are these exceptional cases like
the retrograde motion of of the stars and like you know we have to basically come up with little
supplemental riffs on Ptolemaic astronomy to be able to explain them so it's like ah the stars do a
little you know every once in a while they're coming around the earth and then they just do a little
and then that didn't quite you know solve the problem so they did a little
doop and then another little smaller doop and then they realized in order to have to smooth out the
the experience with the mathematical models they had to do like an infinite number of little oopsie
doopsies you know that got progressively smaller each one to account for the it just became easier to go
with Copernicus it's like exactly what happened is like I can we can either add an infinite number of
these little you know addendums exceptions right or you can just you know redo the model and explains
all of them until you get the subatomic parts and you start having that's kind of like right right
yeah I mean you could certainly make the connection you know between this like the singularity and the
Overman in that instance like something that's unthinkable that seems like an exception turns out
to be constitutive of everything right I mean it's like the Overman is unthinkable it's like it's not
something that's ever there that's ever fully present to us that's cognizable but it turns out it's
actually like part of the grain of relations so it's like that's yeah I mean for me that's why I always
say it's not the future it's futurity which is not 40 years yeah it's not 40 years from now it is
it's as much 40 years in the past right like but we've done this with the logic of being is like
becoming seems to be the sort of supplement it's like there are beings and by the way they change
and I just don't understand I still don't get this with Heidegger like um and I don't get it with
Levinas like why what is the effort why don't they just take up the terminology of becoming
I mean or at least tell me why they don't take up the terminology of becoming like why not just say
like hey this version of being is actually becoming but I don't call it becoming because becoming
presupposes an opposed relationship to being where it's a serious that's fine it's a perfectly viable
explanation but just tell me that like why not what am I missing that becoming certainly for for Hegel
for Heidegger right like why is that not present right present I don't know I don't have that answer
John I'm sorry he does I mean like you know what Nietzsche is the only guy that I've ever seen that
says Heraclitus is the man right and he doesn't do much with it he just says that yeah and he says
That repeatedly, but nevertheless, like everybody else, is Parmenides, you know, or Heidegger at least is
Parmenides, and it's like, wait, it seems like everything you're doing is pointing towards Heraclitus
or some kind of thinking of becoming, right? Like, right, coming to be, passing away, being in time, yeah, I mean
being in time conjoined is becoming, but I mean, isn't it maybe maybe he just feels too invested in the
the metaphysical, like, uh, apparatus, like he wants to actually tease out becoming out of the the sort of
more conventional terms of philosophy. Yes, I guess that could be it. I don't know. I mean, but at least
but even if that's the case you should at least be like, here's why we're not going to use the
terminology becoming. It would seem like the obvious thing, like you think like, I mean, I have to do
yeah, yeah, it would see it would seem like it, like here's why we don't use that terminology and I get
there's no philosophical history of becoming, the thinking of becoming is doesn't have it, right
being has a long one, um, so I mean, I get that, but why, why someone wouldn't just say like, hey, we did
the being thing for 2,000 years. Yeah, let's move to becoming, let's try something else
yeah, sameness, difference. It's like, okay, I get why you say difference, but I also get why you then
want to complicate and say, well, difference is not exactly difference because, you know, it presupposes
sameness and most instantiation, so you have to rethink like with Deleuze, right? I mean, they does
that with difference, I know that you know 2 and a half thousand years is a long time to wait for
uh, a divestment, but I think this is the time to buy Heraclitus stock. Yeah, Heraclitus coin
before it blows up. Yeah, that's what we should in the next next bit. That's that is the Thinking With
Bitcoin official. Yeah, by all, you're thinking with merchandise with Heraclitus coin, the NFT man
non-fungible token of Heraclitus. We got to get those for Thinking With, we, oh my God, that's our
Thinking With token. It's gonna be a Heraclitus. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I like it. This is gonna be his toe in a
river. Well, yeah, exactly. There you go. But did I tell you? I think I did tell you guys the story of
what happened the day that I decided to go read Heraclitus and went to the library? I was just like
fuck it, you know, I've over the years I've gotten so many illusions, just just all just sort of loose
you know, casual things about Heraclitus, and I'm like, I want to read some Heraclitus. So, you know, I go
to the library at Penn State and like I go sort of find the button, there's books, whatever, whatever
and I pull pull all these but I have like 10 books sitting there and they got Loeb versions I got
this translation I got that translation and I just pulled them all out without even saying and I sit
down and I open it up and five minutes later I had read every extant fragment by Heraclitus and I'm
like, you gotta be kidding me, like this this is what, like seriously, I mean it's like two pages of
sentence fragments. Yeah, and that's it. Yeah, like that's all that exists of Heraclitus
that was the first thing I've taught in the history of rhetoric class this year. I was like this has to
be an uh, an abridgment, but why would you choose so few? Oh no, this is all of this. That's all this is
the opposite of Derrida, and I was worried that it wasn't going to generate enough conversation. My
students loved it, and it struck the tone for everything. It was fantastic. Oh, no kidding. Yeah
because it really is like 30 or 40 sentence fragments, right? Like a couple or two sentences
so it's like whoa hey got some real in-depth version the idea that we've come up with some
like Heraclitus was the philosopher of becoming from 40 like just think of the idea of taking
40 fragments of sentences you've written and being like boo-boo is the thinker of
you know, I've got the answers yep, they're just in my notes
guys that's just like parts of random shit that I was making I was writing down a joke at that time
yeah, I mean maybe it's just more of a miracle that there's anything at all that was written
that we still have. That's right. Yeah, that's right, because for instance there we know that there is
the like, um, you know, Heraclitus Jr. or something who was that who was in fact the brilliant thinker
of becoming but left nothing around and there was no right. It was all burned. Yeah, we just don't know
about that person. So yeah, and in fact he was famous in the fifth century. He was like legendary
everybody knew him and he was, you know, but lost. It's just gone. So so we have stories around ancient
Athens that are entirely built on the incredibly limited amount of stuff that we have. Yeah, and that's
just fifth century, right? I mean that's not that 2500. I mean, that's the other thing. Maybe it's a product
of getting older but you start thinking 2500 years, yeah, again, it's like 80 lifetimes. It's not, yeah, right
That's not like uh no it's not millions no right there have been there have been millions of years of
humans prior to the fifth century yeah yeah like what the fuck were they doing what were they doing
I always they weren't writing philosophy I always make that point to my students when trying to
comprehend the length of history is is basically that when Aristotle and the ancient Greeks are writing
about their ancient past that ancient is more ancient to them than they are to us yeah that's right yeah
yeah I mean it's it's mind-boggling isn't it I mean it really it really is so and just what an
incredibly recent invention writing is and it's like you know it's just a matter it's just developing a
different perspective because I mean I've always known this it's like the facts didn't change it's
just that I never really kind of had that sense of this isn't that long ago right like that when
someone says 200 years ago I used to think oh yeah 200 years that's just back in ancient history I'm
like 200 years like I have known people in my life who knew people that were alive 200 years ago right
like by the way it's one of the reasons why it uh that you know slavery is old and emancipation
happened a long time ago just doesn't make sense it's like there are a lot of people alive now that
knew people who were alive that were slaves right that is that's right that's a hop skip and a jump
and then don't even get me started on civil rights and Jim Crow that's what that's what it was for me
was the I think I told you guys this when I took Tommy Crocker's civil rights class and was because
for me civil rights they were always it was in the black and white era yeah so you know because it was
all filmed in black and white and so to me black and white was long ass time ago and I was like oh my God this
was literally like the years before I was born like within a decade of the of my birth this is not
very long like most of the people that I know all of the people that I know that are older than me
remember this yeah this is like and that's when I started to get a sense of like ah here's here's how
life actually works nothing changes it's all like generations is how social change happens we just
happen to be in the moment that we're in and hopefully pushing it in a better direction but if
you want to look at changes in like women's rights you gotta talk in centuries yeah you know you gotta
talk in generations like black rights gay rights like all these things do not happen in the course of a
single lifetime I mean they just they called that that doesn't mean things can't happen it just means
that a cultural shift does not occur in all in 80 years enough people have to die and enough people
have to be born into a different way of thinking yeah that's all it is it's like in other words this
whole fucking persuasion thing is misguided like we stop trying to convince the 40 year olds yeah
stop trying to convince people my age that we're done right like your your target audience is entirely
like 10 to 20 year olds that's it right like yeah I mean but you're literally creating a different
world for them to to live with that's right right I mean this is by the way and you know I I I can't
believe that I this might be the first time I've brought up Richard Rorty in the entire Thinking With
uh uh history but there's a reason we're deleting it there's a he begins his you know career at I think
Yale as an analytic philosopher and then he goes to Stanford and tries mostly to become a continental
philosopher with some successes and failures and he ends his career in an English department at Virginia
and and you know one of his consistence is like philosophy's not going to do it that we need to create
stories that allow for the possibility of generational paradigm shifts
yeah and that's that's what does the persuasive work and I I think that's you know I don't know if
it's the only way but I think that's I think he's on to something yeah yeah I don't think it's I don't
think it's stories anymore I think it's movies well I mean take a broad sense of of you know story
there right yeah but the I the irony of my position on that is it's like that's what the conservatives have
been saying since I was a kid it's like you know Hollywood is is the downfall and we always scoffed
and laughed at that it's like no actually Hollywood is a major engine it's not the major engine for
cultural change
You want to start a religion right it's not I mean I don't know the pragmatics of doing this but it's
like you just need to get two generations of people committing to a practice not a theology not uh not
any of that stuff or rather that stuff is only useful theology is always written 300 years later
right exactly like you just need a couple of generations of people that commit to the practice
and you have a religion that a thousand years from now they'll be like oh jesus you know you know like
That's how you create that sort of social, but it's not in your lifetime, right? So, so in terms of
building the Thinking With brand, I was just going there, right? Like, you, you want to create the sort
of nugget, there are two functions. One is we want it to serve in a way that creates joy and uh for, for
us and the people sort of that'll be connected to that network; that matters though, and fear, but in 500
years I want gospels devoted to each of us. Yeah, I could give a shit, but I mean like you create the
possibility of turning it into some sort of institutionalized practice or at least for my
interest, you, you make sure that it can't possibly be turned into that, right? Like, you, you create this
is like the Nietzsche thing. It's like how do I make sure that this doesn't become a religion? Right? You
know, like I write this sort of totally egotistical, yeah, that guy became the poster boy for for Nazism
for Nazism, so, you know, John, you just wrote the thing on, you know, the the impossibility of not
becoming citational, right? Right, I know. I mean we don't, we don't know how this plays. I mean you've
got to have... That's why I remember a long time ago having debates in undergrad with uh friends of
mine and it was like who was more important, Jesus or Paul? And I was always on the Paul team, and I'm
I'm fully committed to that, like you actually need you didn't need Jesus, you needed a pr, right?
Like you needed a Paul's the one who started Christianity, not Jesus. Jesus was a, you know, Paul is
jobs, right? Exactly, the wasdiak jobs, right? Like how do you do that? And I mean when you have I mean
jobs is a good example of that and Elon Musk is another variation on this theme. Like these guys want
to be that, right? Like these guys or like the Putin is the old school, like he still thinks he's playing
risk, right? Like I mean I mean he does. That's the Ukraine thing. It's like he thinks he's he thinks it's
still a risk game whereas the techie folks are like no no no it's not, yeah right exactly. The techie guys are
like no no no it's not about nation states, right? It's it's about sort of technological sort of
self-transformation, and I'm I'm on their team, right? Like I think I think that the Elon Musk as much as
I despise him as a human, but like he I think he's right. Like I think that's that's the place to invest
not the fucking territorial dumbass shit. Yeah, still playing risk. Sorry, that's great. Yes, yeah, I would take
the Ukraine with my army, you know? I mean, yeah, that's what it is. That's so old-fashioned, bro, buy
some Bitcoin, god damn, but though but us people like us we are just motherfucking widgets in the game
Yeah, oh yeah, right? Like this is the this is the sort of Marxist me of like yeah, you've got these
people are playing the game. We're just trying to figure out how to carve out a not hellish existence
right within those arenas. Yeah, yeah, yeah. But importantly, there's nothing necessarily
exceptional exceptional about those people. It's just that they happen to occupy those positions
at this time and had the drive uh I guess to accumulate exceptional. They were billionaires
right? That's pretty exceptional. It's exceptional, but I feel like it's like with anything. Like
there would be another one if it weren't Musk. Oh, that's right, it's not. I totally it's not, it's not
singular, right? Right, there would be another Musk, there would be another Bezos, right? I mean it's like
that's right. Yeah, right, it's just better when the Bezos's are more like, you know, Bill Gates rather
than right, rather than Zuckerberg. Yes, like yeah, you mean like and infecting us all with microchips
and yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean I think trying to eradicate diseases. Genocide. That's so amazing. That happens
every time I just taught I said this to the sci-fi class. It's the three times I've taught this sci-fi
class and it just happened yesterday where this is this kind of thing has happened where literally
something that we're talking about is news, right? Like it's it's not science fiction, it's news. And so
yesterday it was or two days ago it was the the Neuralink starting human trials on the brain chip
interface and everyone on Twitter is like oh my god this is just like a Black Mirror episode
that we just watched, right? Like in other words, I'm like because I keep trying to sell them on
my interest here is a kind of near future version not like Star Wars and Star Trek. It's like you guys
will and are dealing with the technological shifts that are occurring in these Black Mirror and other
kinds of you know like The Matrix, right? We did The Matrix last week. I mean these kinds of arenas
and they're kind of skeptical about it because they still think it's sci-fi and I'm like no here the
news from yesterday today is literally this Black Mirror episode is an end point for the technology
that he is now doing human trials on or like her is another example of those in your future, right?
Right, that's hers on the new Matrix and whatever another pop culture one, yeah, and I taught them I
thought that okay, let me, I I feel like I need to say this. I have seen, I mean, I I was in grad school
when the first Matrix came out, so of course, right, we're all like, you know, talking about Baudrillard.
Anyway, and so in in the context of the Matrix and but for the most part we all sort of saw it as like
you know, it's this cute philosophical addition to basically an action movie or whatever uh and over
the years other way uh, you know, through the years like I've probably seen it five six times over the
years and I've always liked it. It's like it's very sexy, very pretty, and like I've always enjoyed the
first Matrix um, but I watched it about three weeks ago and decided to teach it since the new Matrix
was coming out. I'm teaching a sci-fi class. I was like okay I'll put a front in the Matrix so we can watch
both the first and the fourth one and I re-watch the first one taking notes and I'm like this I'm not
certain that this is not the most brilliant movie I've ever seen and I'm not even joking
like it certainly went from just being a sci-fi movie that I kind of liked to top five like it's
certainly in my top five smartest most interesting at every level right like every I was I was blown
away in terms of paying kind of close attention to it how fucking smart it is like even the schlocky
Hollywood like romance thing where the kiss is all of that happens in the Matrix right like in the
digital space of in other words like not outside in the in the in the shadow world right like all and
that's an interesting because in number four that becomes super obvious where it's like
it's not really clear whether you're in the Matrix or not in the Matrix if you play out the thinking
and also that it maybe doesn't matter right like I I just think that these movies and I haven't
watched two and three so I can't claim on two and three but number one for sure and at least the
first 40 minutes of number four I'm just like I really think these are no joke like possibly the
smartest movies I've ever seen I I I because I hadn't yeah I hadn't watched the Matrix the first
one for years watch one like what I did in advance I mean over Christmas break I did I was like holy
shit this is so much better than I remember so much better than maybe I'll watch it tonight
it's so it's brilliant and like everything from the from the get-go
I mean everything about it it's just it's so so incredibly conceived and the lines like the the
dialogue right like you know it's just like it's not enough to what's the recurring thing like the
Oracle scene is to me like a crucial scene in in the first one but you know where she says like
she has to know thyself over right what's really gonna bake your noodles would you have knocked the
base over it's a total aside comment that that you first when you watch it you just think oh that's
kind of clever but when you think through it that's exactly what she does she creates a circumstance
where she tells him you're gonna have to choose between kill you know what I mean like she replays
the vase scene with the with Morpheus dying or him dying yeah and you're like I did not see in that
whole note the know thyself that she has over there that she actually kind of treats she's like know
thyself but she actually treats it dismissively which is perfect which is like it's not enough to
know you have to walk the path right you have to do it you have to act right you have to do something
you can't just know something man yeah yeah good shit it's doing it's like it it out Baudrillard
because remember Baudrillard's line his criticism of it and I got it it's like well the problem is
there's such a clear distinction between the digital world and the and the real world this is not
you know the mate what was his line? The Matrix is a movie that the Matrix would make about itself.
and and if you watch number four four four is that four is like oh by the way that first movie
that was a video game? Yeah I mean you're like whoa that whole thing you have to do it like uh um
Keanu Reeves, whoa
well I need to see them now have you not make care I haven't seen the first one either I've never seen
no yeah I could make what were you doing in 99 I was five yeah holy yeah I was just a little wee baby
it's it's I didn't even realize you know what I because I had you know like the last time I
saw it you know it's pre-grad school probably pre-university and you know I was certainly pre having
read Baudrillard uh but I didn't notice that like in the beginning of the one where like he's you know
the computer hacker that's like you know making his hustling his money and he gets the cash and he puts
it in a false book and it's simulacrum simulation baby it's Baudrillard yeah welcome to the desert of
the real the the other one that I came up I was just like fucking around one night when I was teaching
Them and this girl that I'm kind of seeing right now. I mean, I called her up so excited about this and and
she was willing to go with me on it so I actually learned a little bit about the bullet time like
that's the signature look and that the problem now is you can't watch that and see it. It's a cliched
visual but at that time it was fucking mind-blowing we had never seen anything like that in a film or
anything you know it was mind like how did they stop the action and move the camera around him and of
course the answer is they had this string of cameras right like actual cameras that snapshotted
time sequence snapshot and then they CGI'd the the difference between those different images so they
got 500 images from the cameras and then they CGI'd the connection to give it the appearance of
movement what that actually means though is that Neo filmically is part analog and part digital which is
fucking the what the movie is about right wow and you're just like holy shit like at the level of
the technology and I'm not saying that the Wachowskis thought about that who cares like that's actually
one of the lessons is that it's not about knowing and understanding it's about doing right like so I
don't need to claim intention at all but I can say like the technology itself is thematically connected
yeah yeah and you're just like yeah see what I'm saying absolutely like holy shit yeah yeah now this
was before CGI you never saw CGI right like CGI didn't really like now it's absolutely part kind
of like was one of those monumental right right that still looks good by the way like those dinosaurs
90s yeah yeah that's wild and most of that was like like big animatronic shit they must have just
made those look stuff yeah they must have just made those look really good spent millions of dollars
on those but they did CGI in in the sort of the further away ones right right animatronics were
the close ones I mean like you know compared to that and like Jaws from just you know like frankly that
was like well just like what six years earlier seven years no no Jaws was like yeah
Jaws was in the late 70s oh it was in the late 70s I thought it was early 70s 77 I think but you can
see like there's a moment where the shark bites the thing and you can see the the seam on the thing
you're like yeah that's really not a shark yeah yeah you can see the price tag you should you're in
Nate, you're in for a treat. Like uh, I mean I I you know I watched it take taking notes like I was taking
notes for a class like pausing it and writing and I mean I just had and the thing that's striking to
me is I've watched this many times over the years enjoyed it had it and back in grad school had many
conversations about it and I saw new shit like I mean I was like oh my god I never thought about
this and I never thought about like just elements that I mean it's still 20 years later thought
provoking yeah you know after seeing it 10 times and I'm like what else is the criteria for a great
movie you know of like over 20 years it continues to generate new thinking in relation to it I you know
mind-blowing I gotta see it then it's on HBO Max I just looked it up so yeah it's on Max and you just
missed because four just stopped streaming a week ago because that's why yeah oh man wait why
that was just a day they whatever they set the date the streaming would go until that date so now you
have to buy it or what it's movie either it's actually in theaters oh okay well I I don't
fucking know oh well I can see if I can grab it but I'm sure you can you guys can find it yeah well
I could just like yeah if I really wanted to stream it I could pirate it somewhere yeah yeah
so we're gonna do Grammatology next week then okay okay sounds good to me if you have thoughts
on what I should write a lecture about I'm always joneson for lecture although it seems to come it
seems to emerge from yeah reading and thinking through the shit I mean I don't I don't know yeah
those were good the last one too especially felt like I mean maybe at least implicitly driven by some
of the podcast conversations that we've had like the the relation in and through alterity all that
even though we never read Levinas I mean it was like that it still felt like that lot the lines of
thinking that we've taken kind of seemed like they informed uh some of those lectures a little did you
like my Thinking With shout outs there like they were you know where I actually used the phrase
Thinking With dot dot dot I think the results of this Thinking With can be a shift from a critical
orientation to one that is simply trying to follow the thinking construction building through which
the me becomes indistinguishable from the not me
So
the me is